foreign
Amy is with us in Chicago hi Amy welcome
to the Ramsay show
hi thanks for taking my call sure what's
up my question is is a concert debt that
you paid off to come off your credit
report but then return on your credit
report the next month on a little bit of
context we just finished baby step two
in July my husband and I paid off twenty
eight thousand dollars in student loans
in July it came off of our credit
reports and then last week I got an
email saying our score has been
increased by 78 points
um and then our loans are listed again
okay
um
no that's not common
um it's um so here's the thing 52 of the
credit reports have errors
36 percent of them have errors that are
so egregious it could keep you from
getting credit
yeah okay so This falls in the category
of error obviously and I think I know
how it happened I'm not a hundred
percent sure what to do about it there's
a couple of things you can try but
um uh what happens is that these massive
companies in this case the student loan
servicer uh they do downloads usually
quarterly to the uh of their database to
the uh to the credit bureaus okay so
what happened was a single item
was removed as a single item and then
when they downloaded their latest data
it still had your student loan in it
they hadn't taken it out of that piece
of data so when they did the batch
download you were in the batch again
that's what put it back on there I'm
pretty sure
okay so it I would do two things to get
it off number one call the idiots this
is the problem of student loan services
they're absolute morons
I mean it's just you've had to deal with
them before right I mean it's like oh
yeah like are your parents cousins I
mean what is wrong with you people you
know it's just they can't find their
butt with both hands it's ridiculous how
inept they are so but there's nothing
you can do about it except fight through
the bureaucracy so
call them like 62 times because that's
what it'll take and tell them to get the
stupid thing off your credit report
again because it's paid off
would you please note the file is zero
balance now please turn that into
whoever who is it Experian or who is it
yeah experience yeah and and poor
Experian they're dumb as they are too
because they just take whatever these
people send them and load it on there
right with no thought whatsoever that it
might be full of Errors By some goob
that didn't key you know entering key
data that doesn't care so um this is
what you're dealing with just a whole
bunch of in-app people that don't care
so that's one thing you can do is call
them two or three four times maybe
they'll take it off again the other
thing you can do
is with any debt on your credit report
you have the right according to Consumer
Fair Debt or uh Fair Credit Reporting
Act federal law to dispute in writing
any item on your credit bureau report
if they do not
repair the error
within 60 days you have the right to
require them to completely remove it
the whole item as if it never existed
okay and so uh what I would do is just
dispute this item send it to Experian
return receipt requested so you have or
FedEx so you have a date of delivery
proof when the 60 day started okay you
have 60 days from this date
to prove the accuracy of this item it is
inaccurate it should be a zero balance
if you have not corrected it within 60
days you will be forced to remove it I
will force you according to the federal
Fair Credit Reporting Act write that
down Federal Fair Credit Reporting Act
so any of you that have an error on your
credit report that's how you that's how
you get the error fixed now here's what
normally happens in the real world not
the land of Law and a theory in the real
world when you do that almost never so
Experian will send it out to the loan
servicer navient or whoever it is then
right
you know the the loan servicer is almost
always too incompetent to respond within
60 days
so Experian will hear nothing back from
them to correct the error within 60 days
and so then you'll go back and go you
haven't heard anything take it off now
the problem with that is the next time
they download a batch an X quarter it
may show up again
yeah that's possible okay but and so uh
I you know I probably am going to go
ahead and do both I'd fire off the
letter Federal Affair credit reporting I
get the 60 days started and in the
meantime I start calling navient or
Sally May or whoever the flip this is
and just wearing them out
you know that is our new carrier now so
it's who
Nelnet oh yeah yeah great
it's still not any better but I mean no
no have you called them yet by chance
have you already called it but did you
already call them I have yeah I closed
and they see a video on their end so
they're they're not sure why it shows up
like that is what they tell me
yeah well
here's what I'm sure of
you reported it to him wrong
that's what I would tell them so you
guys need to call the you need you need
to send a note over and tell them to
take it off
like now or I'm gonna file suit on you
people
and by the way man what was your name
I'm gonna just you know I want to get
the person on the other end's name
because I won't blame you in the lawsuit
so you need to get off your assets and
get this fixed
right jack them up exactly Jack them up
because they deserve it and you know I'm
not gonna be you know I'm not gonna be
mean until they just persist in their
you know belligerent incompetence and
then we can turn it up we can turn it up
we can make we can make a hobby out of
you people you know and that's what I
would do I you know because you need to
get this off of there and the problem is
if you were dealing with normal human
beings you just call up and they go oh
my bad I'll call and get it off okay but
we're not dealing with normal human
beings we're dealing with student loan
services and credit bureaus and it's
just the it's like dumb meets Dumber you
know
and it's just God what a what an
aggravating industry it's just there's
it's just
so so that you know don't let me help
you guys with this life hack okay some
of you are going oh I've got bad credit
on there I could lie
and write it and dispute it they'll
probably never correct it so I can make
them take the whole thing off well that
may work but it'll be temporary until
they download next quarters
batch of data and then you'll be right
back on there so you've wasted all your
time so you've got to go to the root and
dig out the dandelion otherwise it's
going to keep showing up on stinking
Experian TransUnion whoever whoever
you're dealing with over here so
um you got to get the thing dug out by
the root and the root in this case lives
over at the student loan service or God
help us um